what a day already huh yeah i drove into
work this morning it was still dark
outside sherry saw the lightning around
and now as we've got daybreak we can see
what's going on outside yeah very very
cloudy very low clouds and we're getting
in some live pictures right now from
cornerstone park in henderson that's
where our live crew is this morning
armando navarro bringing us a live
picture and well it looks like the ducks
and the geese are loving it out there
right
right right
they're getting a nice bath from mother
nature and if you've had some heavy rain
around boulder city and henderson
especially in the southwest valley maybe
you want to turn those sprinklers off
save some water and save a little money
on your water bill all right look at
this beautiful shot looking to the
northwest in the mountains and the very
low clouds we've had almost a half an
inch of rain up there at kyle canyon
road some heavy rain though still
focused on u.s 93 and u.s 95 southeast
of the las vegas valley and again
stretched out from around boulder city
up to henderson we've been getting some
moderate rainfall we've had over a
quarter of an inch of rain in that area
down around boulder city very heavy rain
earlier this morning around prim as well
as gene and down around laughlin so
these showers and thunderstorms all have
been sliding in from the southeast to
the northwest and we'll continue to
watch this at least for the next hour
through the morning commute and then i
think we'll start to see a break
temperatures are delightful we're in the
70s even boulder city is down to 68
degrees wow
it's been a long hot summer and it's so
nice to get some nice comfortable
temperatures so we'll see some 80s
through the morning hours i think we'll
take a break midday
the mid morning to midday we'll see
clouds and some sunshine we'll try to
get some 80s back and see if we can make
it into the low 90s today we may not
make it depending on the cloud cover
chance of thunderstorms returns this
afternoon into tonight and maybe heavy
rain on the way for tuesday 6 33 let's
check the wet drive yes so when you just
look at the traffic map looks like a
regular old rush hour some crowded 15
around the spaghetti bowl crowded on the
215 but when we put the rain on top of
it sherry was just saying henderson and
boulder city you are really getting
clobbered right now and the nevada state
police highway patrol have 14
crashes that they are currently working
here are five of them three of them on
the northbound 15. one way on south at
star a crash north 15 at spring mountain
a crash north 15 at sahara two crashes
on the 215 southern beltway that we know
of one of them is at round eastern
another one is westbound around
stephanie also very heavy rain up on
mount charleston an earlier crash should
be clearing for you on the northbound 95
to summerlin parkway there's an active
crash right now really slow going on the
215 eastbound around decatur blocking
the left shoulder blocking the right
lane brock blocking the right shoulders
meantime another crash that was on the
i-15 actually just off the 15
at twain and dean martin drive i know
they were moving the camera around
because there's one of those crashes on
the 15 but around hotel rio dean martin
and twain a very serious crash john
heather we'll keep an eye